there's three wine bottles and you've
got a low medium high when people try it
if they're the exact same wine bottle
people still perceive the value of the
expensive wine bottle as better now
here's the flip side if I were to say go
to Chipotle and you rung up and it was
30 you might feel like you got totally
gypped even if Chipotle is an
exceptional product it is exceptional in
relation to its price that is the entire
concept behind giving away free things
that are exceptional if you take
something that's mediocre and then you
make it free people will perceive it as
more valuable on the flip side if you
need someone to be invested emotionally
in order to succeed then raising the
price gets them more invested in the
outcome it's a dance between these two
extremes which seem contradictory but
are also both true